I don't have any slides because I
decided to talk like 18 minutes ago so
my name is Chris Pfeiffer and I'm the
head of data science at cluster truck
and so I thought I'd use this as an
opportunity to explain what makes us
different from a real restaurant and or
a traditional restaurant and how we use
data to our advantage so in a
traditional restaurant they have data
that they call the P mix or the product
mix and this is the main thing driving
their menu decisions and what this is is
just how many of each item on their menu
that they've sold each week and at
clustered truck when we launched it was
important for us to have that same P mix
so that our chefs could look at that and
the way that they're used to but we also
are able to go much deeper since we're a
vertically integrated digital-only
kitchen so really quickly how many
people have heard of cluster truck or
tried cluster
okay so closer truck is basically a tech
enabled delivery only kitchen so the
main difference between us and someone
like doordash or grub hub is that we
cook all our own food and manage our own
menu and our engineered 100% for
delivery instead of basically attaching
digital ordering and delivery to
existing restaurants so what we look at
in addition to the traditional P mix is
for a certain item if someone ordered it
for the first time what percentage of
the time do they come back and order
plus a truck again we also look at for a
certain item if somebody ordered that on
their first order what percent of the
time when they do order again are they
ordering that same item versus something
else and so if we use this to optimize
not only the most popular menu items but
the menu items that are more likely to
result in a longer term more valuable
customer so another thing we're able to
do differently than a traditional
restaurant by leveraging data is that in
a traditional restaurant if someone was
if something was wrong with your meal
you would you'd say that to your server
they would maybe go back to the kitchen
have them modify it tweak it and then
bring it back out but that data wouldn't
be getting captured anywhere well those
types of errors are even more critical
for us because our customer is not
eating our food at the restaurant
they're eating at their home or their
workplace and so what we've done is
engineered systems that allow when we
get issues through a customer experience
team we document classify and store all
those and our culinary team has custom
data tools to look through all the
different types of issues that are
happening what items have the most
issues which kitchens have the most
issues and how is that varying across
items so for example if the Indianapolis
kitchen is always nailing the apple with
chicken salad and the Columbus Ohio
kitchen is always messing that up and
has a high error rate we can look at
what are those two kitchens doing
differently and we can use this data to
drive action and actually result in a
better result for the customer so that's
another way we use data differently than
a traditional restaurant the other thing
we can do is in a restaurant you may
have no traceability to a transaction so
if someone pays with cash or if they pay
with card and then a different card next
time you don't really know how that
customer is behaving over the long run
we use customer data because you always
have to have a digital account to order
cluster truck we can track lifetime
value of customers and figure out where
our most valuable customers are coming
from and where they're getting delivery
to and then therefore push for
attraction in venues that are similar to
where the most valuable customers are
coming from not just the most customers
are coming from another way you use data
to our advantage differently than a
traditional restaurant and the
traditional restaurant you walk in and
they say we're on a weight right now
it's going to be about 20 minutes and
they're doing this by essentially just
like looking at their wait list and kind
of looking at their watch and making a
guess and most the time they're erring
on the side of caution so that you'll be
pleasantly surprised that your weigh
time was less than what it was but you
really don't know how long it's going to
take but when you come to cluster Trucks
website you have no visual clue of how
busy we are because you can't see it a
line out the door you can't see the
server's looking busy or anything like
that so what we do is we use machine
learning to predict to you how long it
will be if you were to place your order
right now for your food to get delivered
and we're able to do this much better
than our competitors like doordash and
GrubHub
because we're vertically integrated we
have insight into what everyone's
cooking how busy each station is how
many orders are being withheld until we
have the driver bandwidth and Driver
bandwidth or cook bandwidth to cook them
and so basically we're able to leverage
machine learning to predict our wait
times with an average error of about
four and a half minutes so that's some
of the ways that cluster truck leverages
data to be different than traditional
restaurants and we're still just kind of
at the beginning of understanding how
powerful what we can do with the data
what we have is thanks
[Music]